hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and i just wanted to remind you
that we are a not-for-profit and we can
only exist through donations from folks
like yourself
our goal is for everyone to reach their
potential potential is everywhere
unfortunately access is not and that's
what khan academy exists to change
we are trying to reach tens of millions
of students around the world students in
historically under-resourced communities
working with school districts in the u.s
working with stakeholders from from
around the planet to make sure that
students have a way to fill in their
gaps learn at their own time and pace
have access to truly rigorous course
materials
so i encourage you to think about
supporting khan academy the social
return on investment on khan academy
we're about the budget of a large high
school
but we reach already a chunk of humanity
and we want to reach many many more with
over 140 million registered users today
and hopefully billions going forward so
please think about making a donation if
you've benefited from khan academy you
know you know from folks who who've
benefited from khan academy or
maybe most importantly if you want to
see tens to hundreds of millions to
billions of other students benefit from
these resources please think about
making a donation
thank you